Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen. Ich freue mich, dich hier in der Meta-Ebene begrüßen zu können.
Ja, ich freue mich, hier zu sein und Tim, weißt du, du bist einfach so in so richtig guter Form, so richtig gute körperliche Form schön.
Logbuchennetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertsechsundzwanzig, wieder mal ein engen Termin, noch gerade soeben äh gesichert, um äh nochmal eine Sendung abzuliefern, denn ihr merkt ja schon um uns herum
ist ja auch schon Einschränkungen durch Urlaube und so weiter, nicht bei uns zum.
Nicht bei uns, nein. Und das Datum, der siebzehnte Juli.
Der sitzende Juli ein Montag.
Wollen wir jetzt hier mal direkt äh gar nicht erst abbrechen lassen?
Und es ist früh.
Ja ich muss gleich zum Flughafen, so früh ist das.
So früh ist. Also fast schon zu spät.
Ja, war irgendwas?
Äh wir haben viel aus dem Auswärts zu berichten. Vielleicht ganz kurz äh Feedback zur letzten Sendung. Die letzte Sendung war ja auch
äh fast ein bisschen zu früh. Wir haben ja äh richtig so richtig schön äh Sachen rausgehauen, die erst äh nach und nach in den, in den Medien dann auch aufgenommen wurden. Es gibt natürlich einmal so die Medien,
äh die jetzt zu diesen dann noch, also lange mehrere Tage, so diesen Tenor hatten, äh den die Demonstranten zu delegitimieren, ähm,
hast du das bei der Bild mitbekommen, diese äh Kopfgeld ausgesetzt, die hatten irgendwie Fotos von von Straftätern oder vermeintlichen Straftätern.
Wo sich dann auch herausstellte, dass die gar nichts damit zu tun hatten.
Na der Ei, also das wird sich jetzt irgendwo, das weiß man jetzt noch gar nicht, ne? Aber.
Aber sowas sowas gab's auch, ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht, ob das mit der Bild.
Also ich habe das nur irgendwie, ich musste zweimal in so einer Bildzeile vorbei Seite vorbeigehen. Das erste Mal war, wer sind diese Leute? Und das zweite Mal war irgendwie ein
Einer hatte sich dann gestellt und haben sie irgendwie gesagt, ja er wohnt noch bei seiner Mama und haben dann halt also das ist gut abgegangen.
Ähm gleichzeitig Bildzeitung hat glaube ich auch äh dann äh Spenden. Da konnte man dann spenden für die Polizisten,
ja? Äh die die da in äh die da im Einsatz waren. Und was man natürlich, äh, was wir ja in der Sendung relativ ausführlich hatten, wenn wir gegen die Delegitimation des Protestes da mal
angesprochen.
Also die Bildzeitung hat so quasi so eine Rudi Dutschke Gedächtniswoche eingeleitet sozusagen.
So wie sie früher auch immer schon über alles hergezogen sind.
Ja, da die waren wirklich sehr sehr stark bemüht und da ist auch genau der Effekt eingetreten, den wir am Ende der Sendung schon prognostiziert hatten. Zumindest auf diesem Niveau der Berichterstattung. Ähm bei den Qualitätsmedien, also Lügenpresse.
Würde sieht man das eigentlich ganz anders, ne? Also das ähm Spiegel spiegelt diese Woche ist habe ich gerade noch an mir vorbeifilmen sehen, die jetzt Rollen,
Akta Hamburg, wie es dazu kommen konnte, ja? Also eigentlich hast du in den, sage ich mal, etwas differenzierteren Blättern jetzt Aufarbeitung der Polizeistrategien. Ja, also genau das, worüber wir schon am Montag gesprochen hatten.
Ähm.
Und eine auch ein breites Zurückrudern äh nach ursprünglichen Meldungen,
wir hören, welche Zahlen alle nicht so stimmen, so auf einmal waren dann die Polizisten vor allem dehydriert, also irgendwie stundenlang in ihren äh Ausrüstungen äh vor sich hingeschwitzt haben.
Katastrophale, also wirklich katastrophale Zustände, ne? Muss man auch mal sagen, was da dokumentiert ist, wie die Polizisten da gehalten wurden, ne. Die Berliner Polizisten wurden ja eigentlich doch wieder eingeladen,
Äh ähm und äh die haben sich da also auch sage ich mal lauthals beschwert über ihre ihre Einsatzbedingungen. Und genau das ist ja auch das, was,
genauso kritisiert haben, wenn du diesen Menschen da über Wochen und Monate Angst machst, die dann unter katastrophalen Bedingungen,
ähm ja hältst da äh Einsätze fahren lässt und denen Angst machst äh und die in in wirklich, sage ich mal, brenzliche Situationen schickst, ja dann eskaliert eben die Gewalt. So, das ist so und das weiß man,
ja? Das ist keine, das ist übrigens, was wir in den im Feedback ähm paar Mal hatten. Das ist keine Rechtfertigung der Gewalt, ja? Aber wenn die Aufgabe der Polizei in Hamburg war
das zu verhindern. Und da dafür gibt es eben Strategien, die dazu führen können, dass das eingedämmt wird oder es verhindert wird und es gibt andere Strategien.
Spiegel ähm hatte da ein sehr schönes Interview mit. Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig im Sinne sogar dem also so ein Kriminologen, der Kriminologen sind immer die, die an Polizeihochschulen lehren,
der also auch sagte, also das das einfach das grundsätzliche Konzept schon,
Wie es da zum Einsatz kam, ist dafür bekannt, dass es nur in die Eskalation führen kann und es gibt einfach keine empirischen Belege, dass diese Strategie überhaupt jemals irgendwo zufrieden,
beigetragen hätte.
Ähm schön ist auch, äh die Süddeutsche Zeitung hat dann nochmal so, weil das ja auch immer wieder diskutiert wurde, ne. Rechte Versus linke Gewalt, es wird ja dann alles an allem irgendwie relativiert.
Ähm sagte der
sagt dann also Zahl der rechtsextremistisch motivierten Delikte ist im Vergleich zum Vorjahr um dreizehn Komma sechs Prozent auf eintausendsechshundert Fälle gestiegen. Linksextremistische Gewalttaten sind dagegen um ein
auf eintausendzweihundert gesunken. Ähm auch da wieder, ja, relativieren.
Man kann hier nicht die eine Straftat gegen die andere aufwiegen. Alle Straftaten werden alle verurteilt, gibt's keine äh gibt's keine Diskussion,
Aber ähm wenn wenn jetzt hier von Terror oder so die Rede ist, dann kann man ja mal schauen, was das so, was das so äh,
Was das hier so, was hier so die Rolle spielt, ne, Angriffe von Linken auf Polizisten gab es zweitausendsechzehn viel weniger als im Vorjahr, sechshundertsiebenundachtzig Fälle
ja? Fremdenfeindliche Gewalttaten, Rechter, äh, eintausendeinhundertneunzig
Delikteur, so viele wie seit zweitausendeins nicht mehr. Warum ich da mal kurz auf die Zahlen äh äh Bezug nehme, ist,
Weil die Einzelberichterstattungen natürlich immer eingeschränkt sind, ja? Ähm ein Polizist,
kann den je nachdem wo er eingesetzt wurde, einen komplett anderen Gipfel gesehen haben als ein Kollege. Ähm ein Hamburger,
Bewohner kann einen ganz anderen G zwanzig erlebt haben, nur wenn er eine Straße weitergewohnt hat oder je nachdem wo er zum zum Brötchen holen hingegangen ist, haben wir übrigens auch ganz interessante Schilderungen in den Kommentaren, aber muss eben sich das
das große Ganze anschaut und wo sich glaube ich alle einig sind, ist das große Ganze.
Der große ganze Protest mit vielen, vielen zehntausend Teilnehmern eben nun mal friedlich war. Und ähm das egal, was da jetzt irgendwelche Straftäter getan haben, wir damit nicht rechtfertigen können.
Hier so mehrere zehntausend friedliche Demonstranten wie unser letzter Gast da auf die Fresse kriegen.
Und zumal das ja auch alles schon vorher stattfand.
Genau. Ja, das, das kommt ja noch dazu. Ähm es gibt auch ähm ein zwei,
zwei Webseiten jetzt, die sich mit der mit so einer Videosammlung beschäftigen, wo also Gewalt gegen friedliche Personen gesammelt wird.
Ähm und da da ist genau dieser Transfer, den viele Leute gerade nicht so also viele Leute Schwierigkeiten haben,
Aufgrund der medialen Berichterstattung das noch zu trennen, ja? Zu sehen, äh dass es auf einer Seite Gewalttäter gibt,
und auf der anderen Seite gewaltfreie Menschen und dass die Gewalttäter genauso wenig, also nicht Grund sein können, dass den gewaltlosen, friedlichen Menschen auf die Nase gehauen wird.
Ähm spannend war noch äh diese, also kurz sagen, diese, die eine heißt
G zwanzig Minus Doku Punkt org und die andere heißt Police Protality G zwanzig Punkt WordPress dot com. Die sammeln also da so die äh die Tweets und YouTube-Videos wo, wo irgendwie eben äh rechtswidrige Gewalteinsätze gegen
demonstrieren es stattfinden.
Ähm eine davon war dann irgendwie eine Zeit lang bei Twitter gesperrt. Was vor allem deshalb amüsant ist, weil die größtenteils äh aus eingeblendeten Triez besteht und nach einigen Stunden hat äh Twitter es dann auch wieder ermöglicht
diesen Link zu twittern. Aber interessant, es gab also quasi du konntest den Link zu dieser Seite nicht mehr twittern.
Ja, weil der war quasi so als Mywear äh getagt
genauso getect, wie man auch mal wer äh taggen würde. Da kann man über das Wohl und Wehe von so äh Redacts ähm sich lange Gedanken machen, ne? Das ist halt auf der einen Seite ein Schutzmechanismus, da haben wir wieder diese Dualität äh der Sicherheit, ne,
ne wenn halt jetzt tatsächlich Kiez online gehen, die den Leuten im Prinzip die ganze Zeit nur Trojaner über und jubeln wollen, ist es sinnvoll, sowas zu sperren
aber wenn es dann halt hier darum geht irgendwie Informationszugang äh zu verhindern, der äh mehr als digitim äh wäre dann äh wird es natürlich problematisch. Das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert
Es war halt am Anfang nicht klar, was der Auslöser dafür war, äh wurde dann zurückgenommen.
Die Sperre wurde zurückgenommen nach etwas über also ungefähr zwei Stunden und die Begründung war, es wäre ein Softwareback gewesen.
Den auch angeblich irgendeine amerikanische News-Webseite in einem überschaubaren Zeitraum auch gehabt habe bis man nicht, egal.
Dann gab's äh
äh Beschwerden, dass wir die, dass wir verharmlosende Begriffe benutzt hätten. Ähm insbesondere den Begriff der Entglasung und den Begriff der
Erlebnisorientierten Jugendlichen, ich glaube, Entglasung habe ich gesagt, erlebnisorientierte Jugendliche hat Johnnef Nebel gesagt hm.
Glaube in Glasen habt ihr aber sogar beide benu.
Das kann sein, dass wir es beide benutzt haben. Es.
Ja was ist denn das für eine krasse Sprache, die ihr da euch angeeignet habt? Ihr, ihr verharmlost doch hier.
Genau, ähm ich habe dann mal gesucht, die erste Erwähnung des Begriffes entglasung finde ich neunzehnhunderteinundneunzig im Spiegel. Äh da wird der Kölner Polizeibeamte Michael Endler ähm,
äh interviewt. Ich war mit dem Vornamen bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, aber der Kölner Polizei wird Beamte Endler. Ähm
und sagt, ähm der sagt also, das Spiel läuft immer nach dem gleichen Schema ab. Die Hools versuchen, die Innenstädte zu entglasen, die laufen vorne weg und wir hinterher.
Und dann befinden der Begriff, also es ist,
Die erste Erwähnung finde ich im Polizeijargon und äh zweitausendsieben finde ich die erste Erwähnung des Begriffes,
orientierte Jugendliche, da nämlich von Seiten
Verfassungsschutzes. Ähm erlebnisorientierte Jugendliche bezeichnet im in diesem Jagon eben Menschen, die nicht politisch motiviert sind, sondern anreisen
ähm mit zu randalieren, ja? Also die jetzt nicht irgendwie eine eine politische Strategie verfolgen oder eine politische
äh Ideologie verfolgen mit den mit den mit der Beteiligung an den Gewalttaten, sondern sagen Yogal.
Wo man ja auch in der letzten Woche viele Experten, Richter, andere Leute, die zu dem Thema befragt wurden in Bezug auf die Ausschreitung.
Soll unter anderem auch äh solche Sichtweisen ausgepackt haben, sicherlich nicht das einzige, was dazu gesagt wurde, aber,
Das ist halt auch nichts Neues. Das ist etwas, was man ersten Mai kennt. Die Leute sehen halt, da geht was ab,
Das ist für viele vielleicht nicht nur für Jugendliche, aber eben auch für Jugendliche, einfach auch so ein besonderer Kick.
Ganz unabhängig davon, ob die jetzt aus ähm in irgendeiner Form,
unterdrückten oder benachteiligten äh Schichten kommen,
oder auch gerade eben nicht, ja? Weil sie sozusagen einfach mal dieses wilde äh Ding in Berlin oder anderswo mal spüren wollen. Und zwar wirklich mit der Betonung auf,
dieses dieses krass Emotionale einer einer einer vollkommen aufbrausenden, vollkommen eskalierenden Situation
halt auch so ein Kick, man hat ähnliches ja auch schon in diesem Holigenismus, der eben lange Zeit einseitig immer nur dem Fußball zugeschrieben wurde, ja, aber der letzten Endes einfach nur,
dort einfach gesammelt hat, weil er den passenden Rahmen dafür geboten hat, also,
Polizei, Präsent oder viel auch andere Gruppen präsent äh an an öffentlichen Veranstaltungen, ne? Massen kommen zusammen und da sucht man sich dann halt den Kick. Den muss man ja auch nur
begrenzt her geworden damals und das ist sozusagen auch überhaupt nichts Neues und das ist auch etwas, was wir jetzt hier wieder gefunden haben,
Aber ich denke, was wir rüberbringen wollten, auch ist man muss hier, glaube ich, wirklich.
In der in der Argumentation, zumindest auch in der politischen Auswertung einfach ganz klar trennen zwischen,
Es gibt hier ein Demonstrationsrecht, was ausgeübt werden soll. Es gibt da sozusagen auch eine eine politische Haltung, die muss man nicht teilen. Aber man muss sie auf jeden Fall akzeptieren.
Sowie ja auch Nazi-Demos irgendwie beschützt werden von von Polizisten und wie auch da irgendwie oft auch das Argument kommt, ja, warum seid ihr nicht vorgegangen gegen die, die haben ja hier äh Hitlergruß gezeigt oder was weiß ich, wo dann halt auch immer schnell kommt, na ja.
Man muss ja auch Ermessungsspielraum haben und wir können das doch jetzt hier nicht äh wegen solcher äh Sachen da äh eskalieren lassen. Da wäre der Schaden ja für alle noch viel größer. Und das so eine Grundhaltung hier offenbar in Hamburg.
Komplett ab, also nicht nur vorher schon abwesend äh äh schien, sondern dass das dann im Nachhinein auch jetzt so pauschal mit es hat ja gar keine Polizeigewalt gegeben.
Wer das behauptet, dass es eine Denunziation. Zwanzigtausend. Ähm ja, das.
Also wie kann man sowas bringen, ja? Oder dann halt auch sowas oder man darf die Polizei nicht kritisieren. Bitte,
Selbstverständlich darf man die Polizei kritisieren. Die Polizei muss auch kritisiert werden. Das ist auch nicht gegen die Polizei
Wenn man sie kritisiert, weil die Polizei ist ja auch nicht nur die Leute da. Und es ist halt auch nicht ein Missverständnis für die Polizisten, die da im Einsatz sind, die ja auch nur Menschen sind. Wissen wir auch und die sind,
da bestimmt auch nicht froh mit ihrer Situation und ich man kann den auch nicht unbedingt im im Moment,
Unterstellen, dass sie einzeln persönlich da,
gegen die Demonstranten gerichtet waren, sondern die sind dann halt auch nur Opfer ihres Einsatzplans und und und ihrer Übrigkeitsstruktur, der sie nun mal eben geschworen haben, Folge zu leisten, unabhängig von ihrer eigenen Einstellung in dem Moment
für die ist das sicherlich auch nicht schön, mal ganz ab von den ganzen körperlichen und sicherlich auch äh seelisch emotionalen ähm
folgen, die die solche Einsätze und Grundhaltung auch haben. Es gab ja auch zahlreiche,
von Polizisten, die sich da äh im Nachgang zu geäußert haben und diese Strategie halt einfach genauso kritisiert haben,
auch noch, glaube ich, hier in den Links noch einen äh wichtigen Nachlegen sehe ich gerade.
Ja, also das äh am Ende können wir also bei,
können wir ja auch als dann die Opfer der Gewalt, die von der Polizei ausgeht, auch nur äh diese äh Polizei äh zur Rechenschaft ziehen. Und da kritisieren wir ja spezifisch
die Strategie, ja? Also stell dir mal vor, du bist als Polizist ähm heißt es ja, ab geht's äh nach Hamburg,
Hossa, Hossa, äh G zwanzig. Übrigens, es kommen bis zu zehntausend Gewalttäter aus ganz Europa
ja? Und dann hörst du auf deine ähm na ja, ich weiß ja auf deine Führung oder was auch immer man dann da sagt, ja? Und dann heißt es so, jetzt hier Jungs los, Wassermarsch und Rhein, ne, Knüppel. Und du weißt, okay, da draußen ist der da draußen ist die Gewalt, du bist da drauf äh geprimed worden irgendwie die ähm
Das ist schon vorhersehbar wie Menschen in dieser,
Situation reagieren. Gerade ich als äh ja, dann doch psychologisch ausgebildeter Mensch, mache mir dann selbstverständlich drüber Gedanken, wie man ähm solche Situationen, wenn Dinge vorhersehbar sind, kannst du.
Deine Verantwortung umso weniger von dir weisen, ne? Also äh dieses wenn du eben weißt, wie,
die Masse reagieren wird, wie du etwas weiter eskalierst oder deeskalierst, dann kannst du nicht nachher dich hinstellen und sagen, ja, aber die Gewalttäter waren nun mal Gewalttäter und das ist einfach falsch, ja? Es ist ähm nicht
ist keine kluge Strategie der Polizei, die hier stattgefunden hat. Ähm.
Und dann fragt man sich natürlich auch, warum, ne?
Genau, also das, das ist tatsächlich, warum ist das so passiert, ne? Scholz hatten wir gerade schon kurz zitiert mit seinem äh mit seinem Begriff der Denunziation
ja? Kritisiert die Polizei nicht, es hat keine Polizeigewalt gegeben Freunde, Freunde. Also das ist ja wirklich eine eine sehr sehr skurrile
Haltung, die man da jetzt hat. Ähm.
Ein, ach so, ein Aspekt, ich hatte ein interessantes Gespräch, weil ähm man sich ja auch häufig in in solchen Zusammenhängen dann eben Gedanken darüber macht, dass da jetzt das Auto des Arbeiters niedergebrannt wurde oder so. Und da habe ich mal äh mich ein bisschen umgehört.
Wie das denn war oder wie das denn ist mit den Versicherern. So, in Heiligendamm, also das war zweitausendsieben, glaube ich, der Gipfel, ähm der G acht Gipfel in Deutschland.
Ähm da sind die ist die Regierung quasi vorher zu den Versicherern gekommen und hat gesagt wollt ihr nicht,
äh Kulanz zeigen in diesem Zusammenhang, ne? Also da haben, was die Versicherer da gemacht haben, ist eine temporäre Deckungserweiterung ohne Prämie.
Ja, die haben einfach gesagt, pass auf. Für diesen Zeitraum decken wir einmal alles. Ja, ähm auch wenn dein Haus, wenn deine Versicherung gerade das und das diesen und jenen Schaden nicht deckt, wir machen das.
Ähm das geht rechtlich nicht mehr so einfach, weil das äh dem Bereich der Untreue äh berührt
Wenn nämlich ein Versicherungs äh Chef quasi sagt, okay, ich ich zahle jetzt hier mal massiv Schäden, ähm die zu decken, ich
Laut der Verträge nicht.
Rechtlich gebunden bin, ja? Dann ist das natürlich eine Veruntreuung der Gelder, die diesen Menschen anvertraut wurden, da gab's eben rechtliche Änderungen und deswegen geht das nicht mehr so einfach.
In Elmau. Ähm gab es eine Deckung, ja? Und zwar eine subsidiär Deckung,
Das heißt, alle anderen gehen vor, das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie äh ein Glasbruch ähm.
Ähm am Auto stattfindet, dann ist das eigentlich von der Teilkasko abgedeckt, aber das, was quasi am Ende übergeblieben ist, das hatten die Versicherer versichert.
Und zwar die Prämie dafür hat äh wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Die Bundesregierung gezahlt. Das heißt, die haben einfach gesagt, passt auf, wir machen Deal.
Wir versichern den Rest der Schäden, der nicht ohnehin schon bei euch gedeckt ist.
Ähm und da gab's dann eine organisierte Stelle und wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Schaden hattest äh und der war nicht gedeckt, dann ist der eben in diese Subsidierdeckung gegangen, die hatte die Regierung gezahlt, alles gut. Für dich als Versicherungsnehmer das Gleiche, ne? Also.
Die Merkelsche rück.
Merke zurück,
So, ne? Also genau, das würde halt quasi dann.
So gedeckt. Jetzt kommt Hamburg und man denkt ja wieder so, jetzt müsste man ja denken in der Tat sich langsam eingeschliffen. Verfassungsschutz warnt, da wird es Gewalt geben. Keinerlei Abstimmung,
einfach nicht niemand an die Versicherer herangetreten, ja? Ähm jetzt aber, das ist so ein bisschen Klatsch und Tratsch, den man dann eben so hört, wenn man mal mit den richtigen Leuten redet.
Merkel und Scholz haben ja jetzt so eine staatliche Regelung versprochen.
Haben gesagt, ja, nee, komm hier, wir machen wir haben ja ein Scheckbuch und das, was hier nicht versichert ist, dass das Decken wir dann, ne?
Jetzt aber ist natürlich das Problem wie ähm denn ähm die Leute melden ihre Schäden ja bei der Versicherung, du brauchst ja quasi einen Prozess dafür,
ja sollen jetzt einfach mal die Versicherer alles zahlen und am Ende sich das Geld von der Regierung wiederholen, ähm sollst du erstmal deinen Versicherer fragen, wirst dann zur Regierung geschick,
hält die Regierung Stellen bereit, den du
Rechnung schicken kannst, haben die Gutachter haben dir diese Prozesse also auch da nochmal katastrophales Missmanagement, weil zumindest Stand letzter Woche niemand wusste, wie das genau laufen soll, ne? Aber das typische Merkel Nummer äh wir schaffen das.
Und das wird auch dann irgendwie geschafft, aber wer das am Ende schafft, äh müssen wir dann mal sehen.
Übrigens auch tatsächlich war die Aussage, die ich da jetzt gehört habe vom Fachmann, dass ein äh Autobrand von der Teilkasko getragen wird.
Was mir auch nicht ganz klar war, ich äh,
gedacht das wäre anders. Ähm aber wurde mir gesagt, dass das in der Regel von der Teilkasko getragen wird, das heißt und das heißt, äh wenn's Teilkasko ist, da geht auch nicht die Prämie hoch, ne? Das heißt, hier wird dann äh,
Zeitwert erstattet, das ist aber natürlich in der Regel das Problem, weil wenn ein Auto ein paar Jahre alt ist, ist es nix mehr wert äh und entsprechend musst du dir dann anderen,
Schrott kaufen. Also darf, ist dann trotzdem der versteckte äh der versteckte Schaden.
Eine äh ein Feedback, was mich dann doch, was auch zweimal kam, wo ich auch sagen würde, dass ähm empfinde ich als ein bisschen äh unangemessen.
Ist äh kümmert euch um Netzpolitik, von allen anderen habt ihr keine Ahnung. Ja? Ähm also.
An dieser Stelle sei er nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass äh der Tim seit Jahren mit der Port Love Community,
verschiedene Standards und Implementierungen vorantreibt und wir seit Jahren Ultraschall nutzen und unser Player,
auch die Kapitelmarken hat und dass niemand gezwungen ist, sich das bei uns anzuhören, insofern kann man immer auf Skip drücken, wenn einem das Thema nicht gefällt.
Aber wenn ihr mich jetzt schon darin drängen wollt, hier mal den äh den Bezug
zur Sendung äh darzustellen, warum wir das behandelt haben. Ähm mache ich mal kurz eine kleine Rückschau auf die äh vergangenen Sendungen. Da haben wir einmal äh die Verschärfung der Paragraphen einhundertdreizehn, einhundertvierzehn,
Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, einhundertfünfzehn, die wir vor Kurzem äh äh besprochen haben, nämlich ähm
Paragraph einhundertvierzehn das neue Delikt. Täglicher Angriff auf Vollstreckungsbeamte.
Ähm der ist, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe
in Kraft getreten. Am dreißigsten fünften zweitausendsiebzehn, also kurz vorm Gipfel, ja? Das heißt, wir werden können damit rechnen, dass es unter Umständen erste Anzeigen in diesem Bereich äh gibt.
Gegen Demonstrierende. Das war das, wo ähm also wir erinnern uns täglicher Angriff ist so niedrig,
schwellig definiert, dass da quasi dein Arm rutscht aus, während du weggetragen wirst und ähm dann sagt der Polizist, du hast den aber jetzt täglich angegriffen.
Und da waren die Mindeststrafen so hoch, ne? Es ging, glaube ich, mit mit drei oder äh oder sechs Monaten los. Übrigens, wenn,
jemand von euch in Hamburg war,
jetzt mit einem derartigen Verfahren konfrontiert wird und damit einer solch derartigen Anzeige ähm das wäre dann doch äh für mich sehr interessant, da würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr euch mal bei mir meldet.
Ähm zweitens werden jetzt natürlich
in die After-Maf kommen jetzt natürlich die Grundrechtseinschränkungen in die Debatte. Wir haben äh die also jetzt äh vor Kurzem das war glaube ich im April wurde die Gesetzesreform verabschiedet, da hatten wir noch den Podcast gemacht oder ich den Podcast gemacht mit Konstanze, wonach das BKA äh
Hausarrest für terroristische Gefährder,
verhängen kann und diesen Haushaltrest auch mit einer elektronischen Fußfessel oder anderen technischen Mitteln durchsetzen kann.
In diese Richtung geht natürlich das, wenn man jetzt von äh von Terrorismus redet, der da stattgefunden habe in in Hamburg. Ähm.
Thomas Demizier hat bisher nur gesagt, dass er eine Meldeauflage für eine relativ mildes Mittel hält, das sehr wirksam ist.
Und wer gegen die Melderauflage verstößt, muss eben mit Sanktionen rechnen, davon sollte jetzt in Zukunft mal mehr Gebrauch gemacht werden.
Ähm außerdem in der letzten Sendung noch viel zu kurz behandelt sind natürlich die Presserechtseinschränkungen. Zweiunddreißig Journalisten, die namentlich deakreditiert wurden, sehr ähm interessante ähm,
Verlautbarung des BKA dazu. Ja ähm ist es also relativ üblich, dass wir die Journalisten begleitend während sie da so tätig sind, das machen wir seit zehn Jahren.
Und ähm jeder von denen hätte natürlich äh eine Sicherheitscheck gehabt, bevor er in die äh bevor die Akkreditierung anerkannt wurde oder erteilt wurde, Akkreditierungen werden ja erteilt und,
Jetzt hätten sich aber quasi zwischen Erteilen der Akkreditierung und diesem Enzin der Akkreditierung neue,
Informationen ergeben und da ist jetzt das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen, woher denn wohl diese Informationen gekommen sind, ja. Wie, also auch das ist ja wohl.
Entweder ähm haben die da zweiunddreißig Gewalttäter äh akkreditiert und das erst äh viel zu spät gemerkt ähm oder,
hier ist irgendwie eine sehr komische Information gekommen aus irgendwelchen sehr lubiosen Quellen und daraufhin wurde sehr skurril reagiert, also da sollte die Presse auch jetzt so schnell mal nicht nachgeben, sich das anzuschauen.
Gab da auch noch eine andere, also da bin ich jetzt äh auf dünnem Eis, was so die ähm Quellen äh Lage betrifft, was auch noch kolportiert wurde, war, dass äh sozusagen diese äh Kreditierung quasi mehr oder weniger gebunden waren an diese Begleitung,
wohlgemerkt, nicht nur Begleitung im Vorfeld, sondern Begleitung während äh äh dieses Events. Dass sie dann aber aus Personalgründen diese Begleitung nicht mehr sicherstellen konnten und dann sozusagen eher äh dazu tendiert haben, die dann nochmal aus diesem Prozess rauszunehmen
weil sie quasi nicht mehr für ihre Überwachung äh sorgen können, ne.
Es ist auch schön so, ja, wir können sie leider nicht mehr total überwachen, also müssen wir sie einfach komplett von ihren Rechten äh äh abtrennen. Das ist wirklich eine eine sehr interessante äh Logik,
wenn denn das sozusagen so war, weiß man nicht, man kann nur hoffen, dass hier auch die Presse,
allein schon aus dem eigenen Interesse, aber natürlich auch aus dem größten Interesse heraus an dieser ganzen Sache drei dranbleibt. Ich glaube, wir haben beide den Spiegel von heute noch nicht durchblättern können
Von daher wissen wir jetzt noch nicht so richtig, was äh das jetzt noch für einen Impact hat, aber insofern vielleicht mal ganz hilfreich, dass das Ganze in Hamburg stattfand, weil
das dürfte sagen wir mal für die Informationslage des Spiegels ähm ja dürfte recht umfangreich gewesen sein.
Na ja, also in.
Alles nicht schön.
Schön, dass wir jetzt ähm also dieses Narrativ, die vielen, vielen Demonstrierenden mit den.
Immer noch vielen, aber verhältnismäßig natürlich unglaublich wenigen Gewalttätern äh gleichzusetzen, dieser schlicht, also völlig durch,
Ja, das funktioniert. Das äh so durchgeschlagen, dass es bei uns in den Kommentaren ankam, dass es so durchgeschlagen, dass äh Sascha Lobo jetzt seinen eigenen Podcast gestartet hat. Weiß nicht, ob er das mitbekommen hast.
Ich habe mitbekommen, dass er gestartet hat. Ich habe ihn noch nicht gehört, aber er ist wohl eher.
Da auf Kommentare zu seinen ähm zu seiner Kolumne. Was ich das mache spezifisch absichtlich immer nicht, weil ich das für allgemein ziemlich unfair halte, ne? Also du hast dann.
Es soll auch gerade auf die Komment.
Ja, aber genau nicht namentlich. Also ähm das ist genau das, was ich absichtlich hier als Policy habe, wenn jemand eine inhaltliche Ergänzung gibt, wo quasi ganz klar ist, so dass eine Bereicherung und so, dann wird auch mal der Name genannt.
Ähm aber wenn jemand eine andere Meinung vertritt, auf wenigen Zeilen, ja und die vielleicht irgendwie.
Mal eben runtergerotzt hat, ja? Für viele Leute ist dieses Thema ja auch sehr emotional aufgeladen. Wir haben das ja gesehen, Bosbach, äh, rennt aus der Fernsehsendung raus und so. Dieses Thema kann gerade kaum noch diskutiert werden. Und da finde ich das ein bisschen
Oder möchte ich nicht jemanden jetzt hier vor X tausend Leuten
an die Wand nageln, weil er mal irgendwann nachts um eins was Dämliches geschrieben hat. Und äh genau deswegen mache ich das oder machen wir das hier in der Regel nicht, wenn wir mit den Leuten,
nicht übereinstimmen oder wenn der wenn der Kommentar offenkundig relativ einfach zu widerlegen ist.
Ja also das war jetzt mit Abstand auch unsere Kommentarintensivste Folge das.
Seit langem, ja. Ich glaube, wir hatten schon mal mehr Kommentare, aber es ist lange nicht mehr so viele.
Ich glaube, das war der eindeutig eindeutig habe ich schon geguckt. Es war.
Ortstanding. Im Übrigen auch, was die Downloads betraf. Also das Thema hat auf jeden Fall äh auch polarisiert, mag auch,
Ganz neue Klientel zu uns gebracht haben, die vielleicht auch äh sagen wir mal mit unserem Modus,
noch nicht so vertraut ist. Ja, das kann man jetzt nicht ganz äh ausschließen, wissen wir ja nicht, steht ja nicht äh dran am Kommentar. Wie viel äh wie viel Kontext hier schon aufgesogen wurde. Ich meine, dir ist auch klar, unsere Sendung hat einen gewissen Modus, an dem man sich auch erstmal gewöhnen
muss vielleicht auch, ja, oder der zumindest aus stilbilden ist und wir nehmen halt auch eine Menge voraus. Also oder wir setzen eine Menge voraus. Wir erklären uns jetzt nicht am Anfang äh jeder Sendung. Äh wer wir sind und was wir so machen.
Hallo, ich bin Linus, ich bin Kriegsdienstverweigerer, ich lehne ich distanziere mich von jeder Gewalt. Ist eine Sache,
Das ist äh na das fand ich auch sehr äh also na ja also das sind dann auch sorry, wenn ich da jetzt mal ganz kurz persönlich mal meine persönliche Reaktion.
Ich bin Kriegsdienstverweigerer, ich bin seit so vielen Jahren äh,
gewaltfrei, politisch aktiv. Ich bin auch gleichzeitig mehrmals Opfer von Gewalt geworden, nicht immer nur von Polizeigewalt. Bin auch mal einfach so zusammengeschlagen worden. Ähm.
Behalte das nicht mehr für notwendig, dass ich bei meinem politischen
handeln, was sich hier wöchentlich hinlege, ähm was ich an anderer Stelle im Bundestag äh und bei Demonstrationen und bei äh Events, die ich veranstalte, unter Beweis stelle, da muss ich mich jetzt echt nicht mehr
jedes jedes Mal von von irgendwel.
Nicht gegenüber Leuten, die jetzt äh sagen wir mal, vielleicht sollten wir mal eine eine achthundertfünfzig, sechsundzwanzig Sendung mal eine Vorstellungssendung machen, in der wir unsere Grundmotivation darlegen, auf die man dann immer verweisen kann.
Das Problem kriegst du jetzt auch nicht gelöst. Ich sage, ich sage nicht, äh man muss jetzt mit allem äh äh ja, man muss nicht alles äh akzeptieren und nehmen und gut heißen, die sagen nur die Dinge,
sind halt nicht mal so einfach, wenn's ums Verstehen geht, dann muss man auch in den Dialog gehen. Insofern hauen wir da jetzt hier auch nicht irgendwo drauf. Ich fand ehrlich gesagt ähm
Trotzdem man gemerkt hat, dass dass hier die Emotionen etwas höher gekocht sind. Nach wie vor der allgemeine Stil war, einfach mal äh überdurchschnittlich. Also es ist einfach.
Das ist einfach bei uns so, natürlich, wir jammern immer auf höchstem Niveau.
Das ist mein Podcast einfach so, mein.
Also die meisten, so die meisten kommen da was äußerst höflich, ja? Also auch wenn man mit so eine ausführlichere äh Einlassung war dann immer so. Trotzdem der Podcast ist großartig. So Sandwichtaktik fast,
erstmal lob, dann Kritik dann wieder Lob, eigentlich wolltest du nur die Kritik loswerden, aber der Anstand gebietet, dass das halt in ein Sandwich aus äh lecker,
saftigen Lobpacks. Nein, großartig, gab keinen Streit. Und keine Gewalt.
Genau, piep, wir haben uns alle lieb. Wollen wir mal weitermach.
Ja, meine Güte.
Ja da wo gehen wir hin, nach? Merko. Ah, Meriko.
Ähm ich war ja vor kurzem dort.
Ja, ich war auch schon mal da, aber du warst jüngster und bei mir ist schon eine Weile her jetzt. Ist geiler, oder?
Mexiko ist echt schickes Land, kann man empfehlen. Ich bin da ja.
Wie viel Tage hast du gebraucht, um dich in die lokalen Bakterienstamm zu gewinnen?
Du ähm darf ich inzwischen keine Probleme mehr. Ich bin.
So pulliglot durchspült.
Also ich habe die Länder, wo jetzt ich habe die Länder durch, äh die man durch haben muss, um um, sage ich mal, die die Darmflora eines Jets,
Muss ich mir keine Gedanken mehr machen. Ähm,
und scharfes Essen bin ich ja auch äh großer, großer Freund von. Übrigens, hier diese Schokolade, ne, kenne ich auch, die ist richtig lecker. Die die ihr hier in der Freakshow hat, möchte ich an der Stelle mal. Ich habe unterzeu.
Oha. Ja, die ist geil. Instant Regreat.
Ich habe noch ein Stück zu Hause liegen, lecker. Ich esse sie. Ähm.
Ne, war in Mexiko, war ich in Mexiko gewesen und ich wusste relativ wenig über Mexiko. Ich hatte das ja glaube ich auch hier mal in der Sendung gesagt, dass ich meine jährliche USA Reise bis auf Weiteres durch eine jährliche Mexikoreise ersetze.
Äh um mit den Bad Ombrays ähm abzuhängen.
Das ist ein geiles Land und da gibt's viel zu entdecken. Also ich mag Mexiko sehr gerne.
Und was ich nämlich in Mexiko entdeckt habe, ist ähm ich fliege ja immer einfach dahin und gucke dann.
Und ich habe in Mexiko wusste wen ich über das Land und habe dort ähm ein äh Museum in Mexiko City besucht, äh das von den verschwundenen handelt. Und äh das ist also so, dass in Mexiko,
ähm,
immer wieder begonnen hat das, wenn ich dem wenn ich das richtig erinnere um meinen Museumsbesuch neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig.
Sind in Mexiko das erste Mal Menschen verschwunden. Ähm,
Und zwar hatten die neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig ähm Proteste, Studentenproteste, äh die dann irgendwann äh von der Armee.
Nieder äh niedergerollt wurden. Da hat dann die Armee auch friedliche Demonstranten geschossen.
Wir sehen auch hier, ne? Kennt man man kennt diese Auseinandersetzung zwischen friedlichen und nicht mehr so friedlichen und der Staatsgewalt auch in anderen Ländern.
Und in deren Folge sind das erste Mal Menschen verschwunden. Und zwar, wenn ich sage, Mensch, verschwunden, haben sie sofort mittlere zweistellige bis niedrige, dreistellige Zahlen. Innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Und äh da habe ich eine Führung äh in diesem Museum bekommen von dem
Horre
das ist der Museumsdirektor. Ich glaube, vielleicht findet man irgendwo auf der Seite des Museums auch noch so ein Testamonie, was ich mal für die äh in die Kamera gesprochen habe, dann.
Und das geht aber bis dieses bis in die jüngste Zeit weiter, ja? Vor drei Jahren sind wieder dreiundvierzig Studenten verschwunden und man weiß immer nicht, wo die hin sind. Und das ist auch Teil dieser Strategie des
verschwinden lassens. Ähm man hat ja spezifisch Bezug genommen auf
darauf, dass das eigentlich eine äh von den Nazis erdachte Strategie ist, dass,
verschwinden lassens bei Nacht und Nebel. Und das Teil dieser Taktik auch tatsächlich ist, dass du eben genau nicht sagst wohin,
Ja? Vielleicht hast du die Leute, was weiß ich an die Stadtgrenze gefahren äh und da äh erschossen und vergraben, ja? Vielleicht hast du denen irgendeinen Kerker geworfen und hältst die bis ans Ende ihres Lebens ans Leben,
vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht. Man weiß es einfach nicht. Man weiß auch nicht, werden einfach irgendwie von Truppen, die nicht gekennzeichnet sind.
In Gewahrsam genommen oder auch mal irgendwie verhaftet und dann von der lokalen Polizei da holte dann irgendeine ab.
Ja, so Paramilitärische Einheiten, das ist sagen wir mal Gang und Gäbe in Mexiko.
Und dann weiß keiner mehr, wo die sind.
Das ist aber auch so mal so Terror in Reihenform.
Das ist ja ich weiß nicht, wie die Terrordefinitionsläufe.
Ja, im Sinne von also Terror, al,
Angst äh äh aufrechterhalten, ne? Darum geht es ja sozusagen. Man man das Verbrechen als solches ist im Prinzip nur mittel zum Zweck der Zweck ist sozusagen das Entstehen einer Angstsituation und ähm,
da kann man dann auch nochmal zurückgreifen auf diese G zwanzig Diskussion für Leute, die also da äh vorzeitig äh diesen Begriff in die Hand nehmen, ne für für Ausschreitungen, also das ist schon nochmal eine andere äh
Liga.
Ähm.
Und das also ich meine das ist halt äh entsetzlich, ne? Es waren natürlich äh natürlich ähm es waren Menschen, die in den äh Studierendenprotesten.
Entscheidende Rollen gespielt haben und es hat natürlich dann auch einen taktischen.
Ein taktisches Ziel, in dem du eben die Redesführer einfach mal.
Genau.
Generell halt Leute, die sich einmischen, so da ist das Signal halt klar, mischt euch nicht ein, ja? Das äh wie es hier läuft ist schon okay, weil man muss halt äh wissen, Mexiko leidet.
Auch jetzt jenseits dieser äh schwundenen Problematik seit längerer Zeit enorm unter dem
Drogen äh Traffic-Krieg, der eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein Versorgungs,
für die USA ist, ja? Also die Drogen marschieren von Süden nach Norden durch. Das Ganze ist halt in fester Hand von äh Banden und ähm unter anderem sicherlich nicht nur, aber unter anderem
die permanente Weigerung hier äh durch Legalität, Entschärfung äh rein zu, also Legalisierung von Weichendrogen zum Beispiel Entschärfung in diesen Prozess reinzubringen.
Ja verhindert einfach, dass das in Mexiko in irgendeiner Form vorangeht, ne?
Mexiko würde unglaublich gerne legalisieren, würde aber Mexiko sowieso nichts bringen, weil das der Konflikt, den wie du gerade richtig sagtest, der entsteht eben an der südlichen Landesgrenze der USA. Da
haben die, glaube ich, ausschließlich eine Grenze zu Mexiko, entsprechend auch klar, also auf auf dem Landweg. Du guckst gerade so,
Ja, okay, ich geografie, habe ich echt ähm und ähm entsprechend die geographische Situation Mexikos,
Es ist nicht erstaunlich, dass nach und nach eben die ganzen Drogenbosse in Mexiko äh ihrem ihr Vermögen aufsetzen und nicht mehr in den tatsächlich produzierenden Ländern, die ja weiter südlich liegen.
Richtig, ja? Also da gibt's das natürlich auch, wenn äh gleich, zumindest in manchen Ländern nicht mehr so in dem
Maße, also Kolumbien zum Beispiel hat ja tatsächlich so äh gerade jetzt mit der Friedensverhandlung, mit den äh wie heißt denn mit der Fark? Äh
sagen wir mal einen anderen Kurs beschritten,
der eben auch eine entsprechende Wirkung hat, ne? Aber ein Trampsamerika ist natürlich jetzt überhaupt nicht daran zu denken, dass hier in irgendeiner Form sich da was normalisiert. Ich wollte ja nur sagen,
Mexiko ist ein Land, was einfach auf sehr vielen Ebenen
sowohl im Norden, wo es vor allem die Drogenproblematik gibt, aber halt halt auch im Süden, wo schon immer die Auseinandersetzung mit den Energien Völkern gab, einfach militärische Konflikte, unterschiedlicher Natur haben, die einfach tief in die Gesellschaft,
reinwirken. Wo? Warum? Und jetzt kommen wir wieder zu diesem Warum. Ihr seid doch ein Podcast über Netzpolitik. Wo.
Genau hier.
Warum reden wir darüber? Genau.
Warum reden wir darüber?
Und zwar gibt es da eben eine ganze Reihe an äh Aktivisten, die sich immer wieder um dieses Verschwinden kümmern, ne? Sei das jetzt dieses Museum.
Was ich da besucht habe.
Sei die Mütter, ja? Ja, ja, da gibt's eine, gibt's eine ganz starke Muttergruppe. Ja, die gehen ab. Also, ja, also da sind ja, also ich meine jetzt auch, muss ja auch überlegen, hinter jedem einzelnen dieser Menschen verbirgt sich ja eine Familie.
Ähm die diese gerade diese Strafe des Verschwindenlassens, dieser Ungewissheit, mit der die jeden Tag leben müssen. Da entwickelt sich natürlich auch eine Wut, die organisieren sich in Gruppen.
Dieses Museum von dem ich da gerade sprach, ist übrigens in in sehr guter Lage von Mexiko City auf direkt auf der Einkaufsstraße, das ein ganzes Haus, das muss auch irgendwie mal, also da,
sind so viele Leute betroffen, dass da dass die halt auch einfach Geld zusammenkriegen, ne. Das entwickelt sich jetzt zu einer politischen Bewegung, die laut ist, die sichtbar ist.
Und die dann wieder problematisch ist, weil die kannst du jetzt echt nicht mehr verschwinden lassen.
Und da kommt man dann eben von den Strategien von neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig bis in die jüngsten Jahre zu den neuen Strategien.
Und da wird das Ganze dann netzpolitisch relevant, denn äh was jetzt diesen Gruppierungen.
Nämlich der äh äh der, der einer der Kommissionen, die das untersuchen möchte oder untersucht.
Die wurden dann mit äh Staatsregern angegriffen,
und zwar nicht mit irgendwelchen, sondern mit dem Pegasus von der NSO-Gruppe, also Pegasus ist ein äh ein Staatstrojaner, der auf die iOS-Plattform primär abzielt.
Ach. Mhm.
Der wir haben die zwei Vorträge dazu gehabt beim letzten Kongress, beim dreiunddreißig C drei, einmal von Citysen Lab und einmal von,
warte, wie hieß nie,
Die beiden sind Jungs, die mit denen zusammen den Bericht gemacht haben. Ähm also es gibt zwei schaut einfach bei uns in die in die in die Links, da werden beide äh,
Pegasus mit, ja, Pegasus in Turnals ist der eine. Ähm und dann war noch ein anderer ähm,
Ja, also wir haben, wir haben das Thema beim Kongress ähm ausführlich behandelt, da einerseits aus der technischen Perspektive.
Andererseits aber natürlich auch aus der gesellschaftlichen Perspektive, denn die Leute, die da so dran sind, das ist eben das Citysen-Lab, die haben wir hier glaube ich schon sehr oft gelobt.
Ich glaube zu oft gelobt, ähm damit, dass sie, dass man jetzt noch vermuten könnte, dass sich die Leute nicht kennen würde. Ähm.
Citysen-Lab eigentlich in,
Kanada angesiedelt unter Professor Deibert, äh ein Team aus Leuten, die eben äh genau solche äh Staatstrojaner und Angriffe auf Grundrechte technisch,
Primär analysieren, aber das Ganze natürlich in dem politischen Rahmen tun. Die sind sehr stark verbunden mit dem Fall von Ahmed Mansur,
Vielleicht wäre das auch noch kurz ein Begriff, den du da zoomen könntest. Der hatte ihn nämlich bei der Entdeckung oder der war derjenige äh der ihn,
durch den sie Pegasus gefunden haben. Die hatte nämlich damals komische SMS bekommen.
Und äh hatte die, dem Citysen-Lab gemeldet, weil er vorher schonmal mit dem Citysin-Lab zusammengearbeitet hatte, weil er vorher schon mal komische Nachrichten bekommen hatte und einen Staatstrojaner, okay. So viel zu der Vorgeschichte. Jetzt passiert dieser Gruppierung.
Die in Mexiko ähm diese äh verschwundenen Fälle untersucht, genau das Gleiche,
Kriegen irgendwelche komischen SMS von angeblichen Meldungen über verschwundene. Im anderen so linkt auf einem PDF und na ja.
Ziele, die da äh angegriffen wurden, also Zielpersonen waren. Die Anwälte, die dieses Massenverschwinden der dreiundvierzig Studenten untersuchen?
Ein Akademiker, der,
Die Antikorruptionslegislation geschrieben hat, also Mexiko noch dazu ein großes Korruptionsproblem auf allen Ebenen der staatlichen Macht.
Zwei mexikanische Journalisten.
Und ein amerikanischer äh Journalist, der die Opfer von äh sexueller Gewalt durch die sexualisierter Gewalt, durch Polizisten,
vertritt. Ähm.
Weiterhin ging das dann in Richtung Familienmitglieder ähm darunter ein Teenager, der äh auch äh hier quasi Zielpersonen dieses,
dieses Einsatzes von staatlicher Überwachungssoftware ist. Das ist deswegen so interessant, weil die Firma.
Peger äh die Firma NSO, die dieses Pegasus anbietet, ja? Wir denke auch das habe ich hier häufiger schon mal dargelegt. Ähm Staatstrojaner werden häufig eher von Unternehmen,
gemietet. Wir hatten glaube ich auch schon mal den Sendungsstaatsrojaner SS Service, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Ähm als das jetzt jedes Land seine eigene Suppe kocht.
Mexiko hat seit zweitausend,
elf an die NSO-Gruppe insgesamt achtzig Millionen US-Dollar gezahlt, ja? Also die sind da Premiumkunde, Platinkunde könnte man sagen. Achtzig Millionen.
Euro, die also von äh Dollar, die von Mexiko an dieses äh israelische Unternehmen geflossen sind, welches ähm offiziell nur zur Terroristenjagd,
ähm diese Dienstleistung äh bereitstellt. Tja, ähm auch in Mexiko scheint es aber so zu sein,
Spekuliert jetzt spekuliert, dass dieser ähm Einsatz höchstwahrscheinlich ohne richtlerliche Genehmigung stattgefunden hat, denn die würden sie auch laut den mexikanischen Gesetzen nicht bekommen. Also hier
Ein klarer Fall von ähm Missbrauch derartiger ähm.
Tools, nicht das erste Mal, dass ähm dass Pegasus spezifisch gegen äh Menschenrechtsaktivisten eingesetzt wird.
Und äh nicht das erste Mal, dass das irgendwie fernab von jeder von jeder äh Ration, von jeder Saison stattfindet.
Ja man stellt sich mal nur vor, ein Staatshaber hat so unmittelbaren Zugriff auf das Telefonnetz, dass die Verbreitung so einer Software äh quasi äh on Nemand äh stattfinden kann,
Oh weit. Äh unser aller Lieblingsdiktator Erdogan. Ja, sorry, Mister Trump aber auf dem Platz. Kommen sie einfach nicht.
Ähm.
Hat jetzt hier zum Jahrestag des Putschversuchs im letzten Jahr die mir dann diese Welle an Entlassung äh und äh sonstigen staatlichen Übergriffen äh folgte
hat jetzt zu diesem Jahrestag sich mal erlaubt.
Ein sechzehn Sekunden langen Audioclip mit einer bedeutungsschwangeren Ansprache,
in die Mobiltelefonnetze so einzuklinken, dass quasi jeder, der an diesem Tag,
ein Telefonanruf von Mobilfunknetz zum Mobilfunknetz machte, diesen Clip automatisch vorgespielt bekommen hat diese sechzehn Sekunden bevor man dann endlich telefonieren durfte.
Bei der Anruf dann wenigstens kostenlos? Also so sponsoringmäßig.
So nach dem Motto ja.
Man Premiumangebot buchen, um den um diese Durchmeldung nicht zu kriegen.
Hab ich nichts von gelesen.
Alter, was ist das den.
Du meinst, es gibt dann sozusagen so eine, so eine, so eine ähm Propaganda freie Flatrate.
Das wäre echt geil, oder? Na ja, das werden wir alles, das wird alles diskutiert werden.
Stream on für Propaganda freies,
Ja, ich meine, es ist jetzt nichts Neues, ne, so wie einblenden von Verben, bei Telefon, in Telefonnetzen und dann kannst du aber kostenlos telefonieren. Das ist jetzt nix Neues, ne,
Ja, es ist äh keine Ahnung.
Turkzell Plus.
Ja, also Toksal und äh Vodafone waren auf jeden Fall da mit dabei. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's noch weitere Netze betrifft, aber das sind, glaube ich, auch dann die großen Platzhirsche. Ja, ähm
ist halt einfach krass ein Jahr vorher äh na bei dem Putsch, nachdem äh Erdogan dann quasi wieder die äh Macht hat, zurückerobern könnte, nachdem es ja
ob er da und ich kontra kriegt.
Äh hatte damals das schon genutzt, so eine SMS zu verschicken. Einfach an alle ungefragt, ne? Also man sieht einfach, wie nah hier der Staat am äh Drücker ist, an diesen Infrastrukturen und wenn man das jetzt mal kombiniert mit,
äh der Durchschlagkraft einer Mywear äh,
ja äh kann man noch äh lange drüber reden, äh fand ich jetzt bloß ganz interessant, zumal äh wer auch noch einen zweiten Grund haben, nochmal auf die Türkei zu blicken.
Stelle sich vor, du rufst jemanden an und dann kommt irgendwie äh Ding Dong, geht Angela Merkel dran und sagt, das wollte ich nur noch mal dran erinnern.
Aber das war's auch schon. Boah, das ist so, das ist so unheimlich, oder? Das finde ich um einiges unheimlicher als diese SMS.
Ja, vor allem in Abhängigkeit davon, was ihr dann äh sagt, ne? Oder stell mal vor, Olaf Scholz oder so.
Polizeigewalt gegeben mir.
Ja, aber Türkei, äh du sagst es gerade, es gibt.
Nichts Neues von den ähm in der Türkei inhaftierten Menschenrechtlern.
Sie sind ähm.
Wo wir letzte Woche drüber.
Über die wir letzte Woche schon gesprochen haben. Die ähm keine Ahnung der die lernen türkisch und
verbringen ihre Zeit. Äh es wird, es gibt ja eben die diplomatischen Bestrebungen äh diese Leute äh da rauszuholen.
Und ähm gleichzeitig haben wir den Journalisten Dennis äh Yücel, wie ich wie lange ist der jetzt schon wieder da? Das ist jetzt irgendwie.
Tage.
Tage. Ähm.
So da sieht man mal, warum das auch in anderen Ländern, wenn da solche Dinge passieren uns interessieren sollte.
Sei es Mexiko, äh sei es die Türkei, ich hoffe, dass die äh in der Türkei dort jetzt gerade inhaftierten Menschen da relativ bald raus sind. Ähm,
Aber da muss man sich irgendwann auch mal überlegen, welche Mill haben wir da überhaupt? Und es sieht gerade irgendwie danach aus, dass wir gar nicht großartig irgendwas haben, ja?
Wenn nicht also Erdogan und wenn nicht, dann äh dann eben nicht oder was, ne? Also es ist irgendwie sehr krass zu sehen, wie hilflos man dann da auch ist. Wenn man irgendwie wenn in so einem anderen Land auf einmal in Irra regiert.
Das sehen wir auch in Polen gerade, aber das Fass machen wir jetzt nicht auf. Was war noch.
Hier so richtig nicht so richtig beleuchtet worden bisher, ne? Der Fall, weil es eher so internationale Politik ist und wir reden ja hier ausschließlich über eine Netzpolitik.
Wir reden nur über Netzkritik.
Ähm ihr werdet mitbekommen haben, dass äh die arabischen, im Rate, Saudi-Arabien, also im Prinzip nahezu alle Staaten am arabischen äh Golf, auf der arabischen Halbinsel,
beschlossen haben einen äh ihrer Partnerländer, nämlich
ähm ja mit Boykottdrohungen äh nicht nur Drohungen, sondern auch mit Brokkotten konkret zu belegen. Da wurden diplomatische Verbindungen äh äh gekappt.
Grenzen gesperrt.
Gesperrt, Handel komplett eingeschlossen, Flugzeuge durften nicht mehr einfliegen, also so als als hätte gerade Katar äh irgendwie einen militärischen Angriff äh gestartet
haben sie aber nicht, sondern ihnen wurde halt nur unterstellt, besonders iranfreundlich zu sein und wie es so schön heißt, den Terror zu fördern. Was natürlich lustig ist, wenn man sich jetzt äh die arabischen Länder anschaut, ist,
Saudi Arabien, ja
die ja sozusagen Kopf vorkommen, verdachtsfrei sind in irgendeiner Form Terror zu befördern. Man fragte sich also, was hatte es denn damit auf sich und vor allem, wie konnte das dann eben so schnell eskalieren? Besonders verstörend fand ich ehrlich gesagt aus meiner Wart, also das ist jetzt Saudi-Arabien mit sowas,
Damit habe ich irgendwie gerechnet. Dass aber diese ganzen kleineren Emirate dort alle mitgespielt haben, das,
wundert mich. Zumal die ja teilweise auch nochmal eine ganz andere,
Form der Globalisierung leben als das Saudi-Arabien tut, während Saudi Arabien nach wie vor ein extrem abgeschottetes äh Land ist
Sind ja nun so Orte wie Dubai äh ne, also VAE ist halt äh Du.
Wollte gerade sein, ist aber nicht Saudi-Arabien. Ist äh vereinigter Arabisch.
Ich sage dir gerade, Saudi Arabien ist da sozusagen sehr geschlossen. Während halt Länder äh wie die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, also Dubai und ähm wie heißt denn da mal die Hauptstadt verdammt.
La Budabi, ne? Das.
Dass da einfach schon eine ganz andere Durchmischung ist. Also super internationalisierte Orte, also wenn man mal da war, dann erschlägt einen das geradezu, ne? Gechillt ist so relativ, also ich meine, geh da mal.
Sich mit dem Bikini an den Strand gehen.
Ja und es gibt ja auch immer wieder so Verhaftungen von Leuten, die unverheiratet und so weiter, ne? Also das.
Das ist äh oh, das, ja, ja, unverheiratet und so, da, da müssen die Hotels drauf achten, ne?
Ja das ist es ist nicht Konfliktfrei, das wollte wollte ich jetzt sozusagen nicht sagen,
alle dem da wird schon ein anderer Wind, deswegen war ich jetzt ein bisschen überrascht von dieser starken oder vermeintlich starken Allianz, die sich da zusammengetan hat. Man muss halt in dem Zusammenhang auch nochmal kurz beleuchten, welche Rolle Katar
spielt, äh lebt vom Erdgas, die sitzen da auf einer riesigen Erdgasblase und sind von daher halt irgendwo auch wunderbar reich. Es handelt sich hier schlicht einfach um das reichste Land der Welt.
Die können sich wirklich mal alles leisten, ich weiß nicht, also diese Durchschnittseinkommen ist irgendwie so bei hundertzwanzigtausend Dollar im Jahr oder höher, sogar noch, also äh das schlägt alles
Und ähm die sind also da eigentlich relativ gut aufgestellt und auf einmal das. Was stört bitteschön die anderen Länder,
daran, da gibt's viele Vermutungen, unter anderem ist ja auch Katar der Finanzierer von Alja Ziraja, die ja vor einigen Jahren angefangen haben, dem arabischen Welt ein, ich sage mal, zumindest,
den Konzepten der BBC ähnlichen äh Nachrichtensender verpasst haben und die äh ja zumindest teilweise da einen anderen äh Wind äh in die Medienlandschaft gebracht haben.
Jetzt hat das aber doch, da war doch das musst du mir mal erklären. Der Donald Trump war doch kurz vorher,
In Saudi-Arabien haben die dieses komische Ritual mit dem mit diese
mit diesem Globus, wo alle dachten, jetzt na ja, man denkt ja jeden Tag, jetzt ist er völlig übergeschnappt, aber ähm die sind ja irgendwie dieses dieses was war das für ein Ritual? Das war das nicht irgend so eine Kriegserklärung oder sowas.
Das ist mir neu, dass das jetzt irgendein besonderes Ritual war. Ich glaube, das Ganze war einfach nur
Teil einer pompösen Show, die sie da abgezogen haben. Sie haben ja dann auch sein Bild irgendwie mit dem Beamer auf irgendwelche Häuser geballert und so weiter. Die wussten halt einfach, wie man ihn äh,
und dann ist er abgereist und hat ja irgendwie, das war ja seine erste Auslandsreise überhaupt, das muss man sich mal bringen. Und dann dauert es halt nicht lange und dann kam halt die Nummer. Also man merkt halt schon, dass entweder dort
äh sie das Gefühl hatten, äh mit dem Trottel kümmern wir uns hier irgendwie alles erlauben. Ja oder äh wir haben ihm sogar noch äh extra hier eine Nummer gesteckt, die er glaubt. Er war ja dann auch sofort,
dabei über Twitter auf Katar einzuschlagen, ja hier mit
Terror unterstützen und so weiter, das geht ja gar nicht, weil wo kommen wir denn da hin? Nur dass halt diese ganze Nummer mit diesem Terrorunterschützt ist halt irgendwie absurd. Also ich will jetzt nicht Katar.
Aber der Anlass dafür war ja, es wurde von der katarischen ähm Presseagentur gemeldet.
Das dem so sei.
Ja, die äh die Katar News Agency hat gemeldet, da irgendwelche Iranfreundlichen und andere falsche Aussagen des Emirs Tamim Bin,
Hammert Altani. So.
Und damit war die, war der äh war der Fisch geputzt, weil es war klar, ne, die katarische Presseagentur meldet das. Und Katar hat sofort gesagt, ne das stimmt nicht.
So. Gleichzeitig äh hat aber der war Donald Trump schon längst auf Twitter äh und sagte irgendwie, ja, die ähm.
Äh Katar ist der Nummer eins Finanzier des des internationalen islamischen Terrors, islamistischen Terrors. Ähm.
Fahre jetzt auch vorher unbekannt,
dass das der, dass das der Fall sei. Und das ausgerichtet ähm die Saudis dann da sofort mit mitmachen. Das erschien alles sehr komisch. Und jetzt kommt die Meldung. Also, ne, die Folgen davon waren katastrophal für den Golf,
Also da die die waren lange nicht mehr in einer derartigen Krise, die Länder, die da im Golfrad zusammensitzen.
Ähm jetzt sagen, also dann war die der also Katar sagte, nee, wir wurden gehackt.
Dieses das haben wir nicht nie gesagt und die unsere Ergebnisse sagen deshalb hat auch die äh unsere Presseagentur nie gemeldet.
Ja ähm oder die Presseagentur weiß nicht, wie es zu dieser Meldung kommt. Da muss jemand gehackt haben. Die US-Geheimdienste haben dann gesagt, okay, schauen wir uns die Sachen mal an und dachten zuerst, es war ein, wer was?
Die Russen. Haben sie gedacht, haben aber dann weiter untersucht und haben jetzt, wie wir gerade lesen, ähm zumindest ausreichend,
herausgefunden, dass sie sich an die Öffentlichkeit damit wagen, zu sagen, das waren wohl die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate,
und äh berichten, es hätte wohl irgendwie sogar Ideen gegeben. Also die Idee, diese spezifische Idee sei also in ähm in den, in den VAE diskutiert worden
und kurz danach auf genau diese Weise eingetreten, wie sie dort diskutiert wurde. Soweit der Kenntnisstand.
Das gibt natürlich nochmal eine ganz neue Perspektive auf staatliches Hacking, wenn sich das so bewahrheitet.
Also dass da im Golf,
fortgeschrittene Überwachungsmaßnahmen stattfinden. Das ist ein alter Hut, dass die sich halt auch mit Trojanern et cetera äh
dort nicht nur aktiv befassen, sondern die auch aktiv im Einsatz haben. Ist alles wunderbar bekannt
erstmal so ein Arsenal aufgebaut hat und äh dessen Wirkung kennt, äh der geht da auch gleich mit anders um
Wir werden also hier gerade jetzt im Kontext der Fake News eben auch mit solchen Sachen zu rechnen haben, dass wir hier ganz geschickt eingefädelt äh Ereig,
auf einmal vor unserem Auge sehen, vielleicht sogar von seriösen Gruppen berichtet, die das aber einfach nur untergeschoben bekommen haben,
Ja, dann bin ich heute noch,
zufällig hier irgendwie so ein Video gestolpert auf Twitter, wo irgendwie schön gezeigt wird, so eine äh so eine Demo.
Zu sagen so ja so so mittlerweile in Perfektion Videos, also Personen quasi Videos modifiziert werden, dass sie dann auf eine andere Rede gebracht werden war das ein Beispiel mit Obama spricht halt ein Text, den er so nie,
gesagt hat, zumindest nicht in der Situation, dann wird es einfach nochmal da werden wir nochmal so eine so eine so eine Dimension der Nachrichten glaubhaftigkeit erleben. Das wird nicht,
Einfach. Wir hatten.
Da sind du und ich übrigens als erstes dran, ne? Weil wir haben inzwischen auch genug äh Stimmmaterial hier geliefert, um so eine AI zu schulen.
Garantie. Es gibt sogar schon Stimmen, die sagen, dass seit mehreren Ausgaben nur noch Rennerei am Laufen ist.
Aber so eine AI, ja, so einen ausgefeilten Witz, wie wir ihn da haben. Da müsst ihr noch lange dran provieren.
Lange Pfeifen, da müsst ihr noch lange Pfeifen üben.
Noch ganz kurz zur Vervollständigung dieser Globus, den Donald Trump da irgendwie berührt hat, ist offenbar ohne jeglichen symbolischen Hintergrund, die haben da das globale Center zum Kampf
gegen extremistische Ideologien ähm eröffnet in Saudi-Arabien. Jetzt zusammen mit.
Ist wirklich geil. Da muss man erstmal drauf kommen. Oh Gott. Fett.
Und als ich ihn den berührt habe, ist halt irgendein Video angegangen oder so. Na ja. So.
Venezuela ist noch Zoff.
Ja, also.
Venezuela. Ich glaube, den Konflikt müssen wir jetzt echt nicht mehr aufarbeiten. Da haben wir auch wirklich gerade gar nicht genug Einblick, aber auch da natürlich als allererstes äh Internetzensur und äh ja.
Das war jetzt sehr umfangreich.
Ja. Kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen.
Komm, fünf Minuten haben wir noch,
Also äh auch hier vielleicht mal so ein bisschen internationaler äh Hintergrund, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, Venezuela geht schon seit einer ganzen äh Weile äh äh ziemlich zur Sache. Nicht nur, dass das Land eigentlich äh nicht nicht erst seit dem
Tod von dem ehemaligen großen Führer Ugu Tschaves in den Niedergang schlittert
das hat sich auch vorher schon unter Schavis angedeutet, ja? Obwohl dieses Land eigentlich auf auf äh Öl, äh Reserven sitzt
Ist es ihnen trotz ihrer sozialistischen Regierung und all dem ganzen revolutionären Getue nicht gelungen in dieses Land Ruhe reinzubringen, Venezuela ist
schon lange, lange Zeit als äh schwieriges Land bekannt, äh extrem hohe.
Kriminalität, also da war es noch nie schön, trotz alledem ist es halt nicht gelungen. Na, in der Hinsicht war es nie
schön, ja? Also es ist halt einfach, ich meine, ich habe mich auch mal mit Leuten unterhalten, die da im in der Region äh viel unterwegs sind, von Insel zu Insel, von Land zu Land äh ziehen und so weiter, also um Venezuela
viele schon immer frühen einen Bogen gemacht, die jetzt mit Kolumbien und so weiter überhaupt gar kein Problem haben. Das Ganze ist ja nichts anderes als Ausdruck der
sozialen Probleme und jetzt gibt's einfach seit mehreren Monaten
erhebliche äh Widerstände gegenüber einer Grundrechtsänderung, die da von Maduro dem aktuellen Präsidenten äh geplant sozusagen mal wieder die Opposition komplett beiseite zu fiegen. Das ist alles nicht schwierig, die Opposition war ja auch früher auch mal schön im im Bettchen da
den USA, also in Venezuela ging's schon immer heiß her und da gibt's auch kein einfaches Gut und äh schlecht. Nur trotzdem, man merkt halt jetzt, wie wird halt auch
die Internetzensur jetzt verstärkt eingeschaltet, weil Computer sind da auch schon seit längerem im Einsatz, also man kann dann,
einfach nur noch das Beste hoffen, dass äh da nicht alles komplett hops geht, aber gut sieht's gerade nicht aus. Gibt da jetzt einen entsprechendes äh,
von verschiedenen Gruppen, die sich da merken, äh, melden zu dem Thema, wir verlinken das einfach mal und haben heute irgendwie ein bisschen wenig Zeit und.
Müssen diese Sendung zu Ende bringen.
Das sei hiermit getan.
Genau. Leute, wir haben jetzt äh auf jeden Fall nächste Woche, glaube ich,
weiß nicht, ob du vielleicht selber noch was vom Zaun ist. Ich werde mir auf jeden Fall äh nicht dabei ähm müssen äh schauen, jetzt beginnt so ein bisschen die schwierige Zeit
ne, aber wenn's möglich ist, wenn wir jetzt hier wieder zusammenfinden und äh weiterhin kernnetzpolitische Themen besprechen.
Plötzlich mal einfach diesen Podcast oben in den.
Ich wir haben ja noch den Plan uns mit äh Politikern auseinanderzusetzen ähm,
mal schauen, ob wir das vielleicht in irgendwie, also es steht alles in Gefahr, aber wir wir sind stets bemüht.
Genau, wir waren stets bemüht. In diesem Sinne, bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.